[Music]
fourth underworld movie picks up a third
logo because this studio saw the first
three underworlds and said how could we
pass up our shot at a piece of movie
history the series has gotten more
mileage out of this one shot than I have
from that Katie Holmes scene in the gift
azad darkly lit action scenes with quick
fades to black through them oh
underworld you make my optometrist so
much money the vampire and Lycan clans
had been at war for centuries before I
was born the series about vampires and
werewolves killing each other decides
you need a refresher course during the
fourth chapter also this movie clocks in
at 1 hour 28 minutes 34 seconds plus
credits and so far the production costs
have been cut in half by using old
footage in the nine days since the first
discovery of the non-human species
suddenly this movie about vampires and
werewolves feels like every zombie movie
ever made
giving us news exposition during the
opening credits also how did humans
discover these species there was
absolutely nothing from the first two
movies that would suggest the vampires
and werewolves were ready to simply come
out and reveal themselves is this movie
going to explain this fast-forwarding no
it doesn't also even though all the
battles we've seen appear to take place
on empty streets in the middle of ghost
towns or abandoned highways I can't
believe humans have never seen these
creatures until now there was an open
battle in the subway in the first movie
oh man they dragged Stephen Rea into
this didn't they I mean this movie this
movie is shot like a collage only if you
were to pull back to see the whole
picture would be nothing but darkness
badly cut pictures invisible paste I'm
adding ten sins to this because
underworld action scenes are the worst
the patch no I just saw 10 seconds ago
this movie is called underworld
awakening human beings no longer kill
each other
um total bullshit even if humans rallied
around killing all of you guys there
would still be plenty of human on human
violence because their soccer team lost
to Crystal Palace we are the enemy
they've been waiting for yep we've been
sitting here twiddling our thumbs
waiting for an enemy isn't that how the
Rolling Stone song goes I'm not waiting
on my lady I'm just waiting on an enemy
I can kill with ultraviolet bullets way
ahead of their time those stones do you
mean hold you assholes have been killing
indiscriminately for the last two
minutes but sure gives Selena warning
first also in nine days the government
saw fit to stick this sign on the
rooftop of a random building just in
case someone on their smoke break needed
a reminder about Dracula protocol Selene
just happens to fall into the alley
where a cop was put on flamethrower duty
thereby giving her a chance to show off
this move she learned from Trinity so
here's Michael but
not entirely sure they got Scott
Speedman for this movie is this some
sort of digital recreation old footage
bullshit I think it is on your vaya name
is for alive I know Michaels here
because he and Celine are gonna leave
town but why stand out on a pier out in
the open in the middle of it openly
hostile to nonhumans city like this also
with his heightened senses shouldn't he
know there are cops around especially up
to that one dude used his radio also god
damn this movie raises a lot of
questions in its first six minutes but
at what point did Celine and Michael
fuck this up to the point where they
needed to meet it appear and got
separated and why did they make a plan
requiring them to run through a city
full of humans wanting to kill them
meant for a unit that was told not to
kill Michael they sure do a lot of blind
shooting into dark water hoping for the
best also despite the bullets moving at
deadly speed under water thing being
totally debunked how in the fuck are
they missing Selene right now man you
could have just led with this I guess
the director really wanted to see bullet
trails in the water because they're so
cool would have never been done before
in any movie this is Celine seeing
images through the eyes of a daughter
she doesn't know she has yet and while
it will provide a couple of plot
conveniences is never used for anything
cool whatsoever defrost sequence
initiated
Celine's daughter knew exactly what she
needed to do to get the defrost sequence
initiated
and that's depressed what appears to be
the Escape key with no other passwords
or security or keystrokes to worry about
holy they kept her outfit in here and
everything such caring evil doctors this
lot and they stored her outfit along
with all the formaldehyde and other jars
full of science even though she was
soaking wet coming out of her chamber
Celine was able to put on a tight skin
leather onesie in record time what also
what this didn't hurt me and can't kill
me but by god I will punish you severely
for it though might be a great time to
have one of those knockout grenades you
guys use just four minutes ago God Dan
at West Bentley I once thought you were
better than this thing army surplus
store has a window you can break into on
the roof so lien operates under the
convenient or inconvenient rules of mrs.
Potato Head and Toy Story 3 when it
comes to seeing whatever her daughter
sees whoever it is they couldn't have
made it very far like how can you know
that just by looking at a badly mauled
body near an overpass detective was the
last time you heard about a reported
liking killing a couple years ago how
many years have you been with this too
lead detective will shame this guy for
thinking it's a liken killing without
explaining why it could be anything else
basically the point of the scene is
you're young and stupid and I fucked
your mom eyewitness says there may have
been an escape they said someone jumped
out of a window so someone was just
looking at the beautiful antigen
building and saw Selene jump out the
window you couldn't see that if you were
looking for it you would think being a
vampire for centuries would have taught
Selene stealth mode but you'd be kicked
off the set of this movie
it'll be related to know that the
situation is well under control what
happened I repeat well under control
routine what happened guys we're making
a movie that we're not sure we'll make
it to feature length so let's just
repeat things have stupid arguments and
waste time until we get to about the 80
minute or if you're all going to order
pizza for everybody you had to love it
when you can press a button on a
computer displaying nothing but text and
it shoots out a photograph somehow also
this just happens to be a security
camera pointing right at where Selene
jumped out so I guess the detective knew
exactly what timecode to punch into his
computer to magically produce this
evidence too bad she wasn't this fast
when she was trying to save Michael
earlier I know is it some kind of
connection between you two your
brainwave father Zeke whatever you call
to each other I know it's real in this
world but if you were to see this in a
movie you'd probably leave the theater
as quickly as possible
refund passes are at customer service
just tell them you had a family
emergency
they'll probably give you the refund if
they don't tell them you'll contact the
corporate office the corporate office
usually responds pretty well Wes gently
also was that possibly the least amount
of screen time Wes Bentley has ever had
in a movie why did he even agree to this
hey Wes your character will talk on a
radio in one scene and get thrown off a
building in the next one that will be
all of your scenes amazing how these two
somehow end up close to each other so
often in this big city is this sign
basically saying no trash bins allowed
up done why did you say I'm somehow able
to hide the color of my vampire eyes to
make for more exciting movie reveals
lichens remain zoom yes but despite
their amazing super hearing they cannot
hear us now if it's straight and metal
it starts fans
you gotta love how this random dickhead
in traffic continues to drive the car
with a werewolf on his hood like it's an
everyday occurrence they spend so much
time on this werewolf jumps off the taxi
onto the van shot I was expecting
something cool to be happening but
really in the end it's just a werewolf
jumping on a van now we find out the
vision Celine's been having is actually
at the girl and not Michael my question
is why didn't she have this vision much
sooner since apparently something
something was Bentley crashed into a car
random dude who is important to the plot
just happens to be out on a joyride when
all this
goes down so we can worry about some
other stalker in this movie that my own
mother my next-door never even know it
existed what did they tell you of your
father Celine is in no way amazed or
shocked that she had a daughter while in
captivity and later we find out she's
just got a broken heart because of
Michael but if you found out you had a
daughter you didn't know about and you
were the mother wouldn't that freak you
out a bit also this movie is more 5th
element and species than I think it
realizes wait why is she suddenly
unconscious the last we saw her she was
upright and alert and yeah I know the
werewolf attacked her and she wasn't
healing but it's not like she looked
anywhere near death Breaking and
Entering using an unconscious child
buddy will be make sure that it gets the
best bill nighy replacement by hiring
Charles dance we will play the same
character only with a different name
when did you last feed feet so they
needed to bring her to this coven to
healer but I can't believe that Celine
didn't think to give Eve some blood
first before agreeing to walk into some
other vampire lair where she's hated
because of her interracial relationship
so leans about to crime which gives this
movie the opportunity to once again use
footage we've already been disappointed
by I used to his stories of the death
divas today were thing is a paused how
in the fuck that Celine's vampire coven
operate in secret from the other vampire
covens to the point that the Death
Dealers are like myths I mean Tywin
Lannister knew Celine was dating a
hybrid but not about her death-dealing
and had this series with three full
movies under its belt never mention
other covens know the church and I'm
glad to the wrong because you're hot
seriously candlemaker's your entire
industry is based on vampire and sex
movies right how does the coven
refrigerate this cave full of blood
packets is this a naturally occurring
cold spot located deep under this dam or
are they jacking hydroelectric power
from the good people of whatever this
country is you disgust me
well appearing out of nowhere directly
behind a girl who thinks she's alone
tends to do that when he won't the next
day and then that overnight 12 years
past that's another thing this movie
says 12 years have passed but at some
point when they were riding in the van
Eve mentioned something about one of the
antigen guys saying you're no longer a
child
so was this girl 12 which makes the most
sense or is she 18 which is closer to
the actresses age but doesn't make any
sense just by the context clues I know
they're saying she's 12 but they're
confusing us I won't let anyone hurt you
I promise uncapable promises oh and it
thinks gets trobee in here it's that
part of some sort of vampire alarm
system or is it because these movies
can't stage a battle without making your
epilepsy bleed the vampires keep their
weapons stored on this giant chandelier
thing that is all this day was bound to
come with the without us
yeah the humans totally would have found
themselves looking for vampires in this
remote dam would have pulled up the
sandbags and dirt that cover the secret
trapdoor to this place and would have
figured out how to open the store that
only unlocks with a special key that
would have eventually happened also
we're about to find out that it's the
lichens that have found this place but
did they use dynamite or something to
get inside
who knows also this is sort of the
disadvantage of having your secret
hideout covered by sandbags and rocks
because when you have to use it you
can't cover it back up again until you
go back out and how would you get out if
the door was covered with all this heavy
stuff the secret entrance raises more
questions than it answers
let's go someone please explain why the
antagonists go with the pick you up and
throw your method when they have the
upper hand you're looking at these fangs
and these claws and you're like I don't
know what to do man with this I don't
know how to kill the bunny oh no they
killed this obviously computer-generated
vampire guy who looks like an effect
even Birdemic rejected David will now
proceed to kick tons of ass despite
telling Selene that this coven needed
her to Train them out of fight like in
vampire punching man is anything
werewolves like to do in the series it's
mill about behind curtains and Jesus how
does this not kill her luckily Selene
isn't this dude
cut the black moon black damn black
bodies damn Jeezy's assholes are only
just now outside the dam after all that
time how convenient for Salinas
convenient connection to Eve first off I
didn't need to see that second off
did she just grab his diaphragm and
bring him back to life ping Wow if
Evanescence were still alive they'd
write a song about this wait a minute
when did she get this leather coat
didn't she go to the surplus and
shoplift a regular trench coat earlier
even so that coats still in the van
because she didn't even bring that with
her so few leather coat I guess Selene
no Sebastian's working hours and his
regular parking spot also sure let's
pull this from the police parking garage
that's where I do all my cop threatening
to this goes much higher I believe all
the way to the top what's the bottom
what do you mean it takes Selene to
inform this veteran detective that maybe
the company performing the tests on
lichens might be the ones involved in
the cover-up you said she was essential
to our research by vivisecting her you
weren't meant to have that did these
guys who are doing secret where will
expect this lady to walk in and start
yelling at them because the super Lycan
guy walked in without even being
summoned and with perfect timing really
in the end is this any different than
paranormal activity footage you could
put this in one of those movies and I'd
never be able to tell the difference
from a man named Alexander Corvinus
founding father Sebastian will now
explain that he was married to a nurse
who got bitten by a vampire and they
lived in secret like that for a few
years but where did they learn about
Alexander Corvinus considering the look
Selene gives Sebastian I'm going to
assume that this knowledge is hard to
come by and I'm going to guess this
isn't the type of research you could do
at your local library
then came the purge feds were conducting
door-to-door xand when they knocked on
towers yeah your vampire wife killed
herself before they could but what I
don't get is how they continue to let
you cop after discovering you were
married to a vampire
if Selene can move with this kind of
quickness why not just run all the way
to the goddamn elevator and avoid being
seen all together this is one of two
bullets that hit Selene during this
entire barrage of bullets that had no
chance of killing her anyway it's kind
of amazing antigen is set up so that you
can see an entire lobby shootout from
the street with binoculars sure the
security guards weren't able to get on
the elevator with her but couldn't they
have shut down the elevators
I just solved the biggest mystery in
this entire movie that's where Wes
Bentley is right now even in an
emergency situation or security breach
why would the operating room have
flashing lights all around of the people
who built structures in this movie never
heard of those special emergency lights
you hang on the walls that don't require
a full-on strobe situation I guess these
are sparks from the charges Selene just
blew up but for a second there I thought
something was wrong with my screen which
is way more important
than any entertainment these sparkly
things provide is this guy about to walk
into the evil like and facility without
any backup also what happened to his
partner did the actor get fired before
they shot these scenes
well me kind of dumb luck is it I really
love how these werewolves always seem to
find a way to attack like this one on
the floor two on the wall like this is
some unbeatable formation and I'd like
to know how running on the side of a
wall is even possible
but I guess werewolf physics is
different okay how is Selene missing
this Lycan right now this is a narrow
ventilation shaft
right you should be able to shoot blind
and hit this thing easily wait you mean
she can reload our guns just by swinging
her arms behind her back where I guess
there's a magical ask gun loading
feature if her ammo is so easy to reload
why couldn't she have done that in the
ventilation shaft to kill the other
werewolf
oh wow after navigating a ventilation
shaft she landed in the exact room where
they're still keeping Michael the luck
in this movie is sweet highly-trained
Lycan killer Selene totally whips on
noticing a pin light and running towards
her sure I had amazing Lycan powers that
have never been seen before let's see if
a falling elevator can decide this
Selene attempts to shoot an elevator to
death also sure makes getting hit by an
elevator more palatable when it crashes
into her but a bunch of bullshit well
it's this guy's modest when he knows
he's about to change into a pants
splitting werewolf you're the most
powerful fucking werewolf ever and you
just owned Selene in a previous battle
but okay see if you're throwing
abilities in this they should have just
called this underworld the throwing or
the throwing actually at another five
sins for that yeah good one don't think
it insulted him much though or we'll
keep you alive in anyway
did this guy know to be here Sebastian
didn't radio this in so there's no
police chatter about this going on and
Selene didn't make the connection about
antigen until after she left the coven
okay so Wolfman here is completely
wedged into this office Selene stabs the
guy in the neck and then suddenly he can
grab her make a pirouette and throw her
through the same hole here nonsense
movie it's worse if you try to fight it
glad that this line that Jacob said to
Eve when he was filling her room full of
gas a minute ago could come back around
to bite him in the ass in a completely
incongruent situation this would seem
gross to me if it wasn't so obviously a
bunch of computer graphics they run to
the roof to find Michael who obviously
isn't there because Scott Speedman isn't
even really in this movie it took two
directors to make this movie which
clocks in at 78 minutes before credits
also ten minutes of credits
that's 11% of the movie and when you
factor all the old footage use I think
there's like fifteen minutes of an
actual new film here
wiggle your big toe
you'll Paris enflame where were the
other drugs come it was a teenage
wedding and they all both wished where
my grandmother had an island nothing to
boast of you could walk around it in an
hour but still he was it was a paradise
for us one summer we went for a visit
and discovered the place had been
infested with rats he's here I know he's
here there's a classic case of guy on
the ground our stocks have marched home
the young wolf has lost half his army
his days are numbered
Theon Greyjoy murdered both his brothers
this is even more painful than it looks